you slept in a coffin for several years
at it during a period of your life is
that true or false
yes but yeah why did you lie I never
went to the coffin sleeping face no I
really liked vampires for a while like
The Lost Boys and stuff like that oh and
I liked being this sounds bad
I like being nestled you know when you
do a little blanket but you guys don't
know but you know you do a blanket
burrito or whatever I thought I could go
one better and just do a coffin and so
from when I was 15 to 18 I slept in a 15
to 18 so you didn't sleep in a coffin
once or like twice were three years
three years where'd you get a coffin
what did your parents thing my dad who
named me Brecon was always looking for
projects for us to do and I said I want
to get a coffin he's like I will not let
you buy a coffin it was like that's a
good parent and he's like but we can
build one I'm not kidding I mean like my
dad he could raise a barn I mean they
were it was nice it crown molding on the
side satin lining lid everything I will
always win the weirdest place did you
have sex contest
you had sex in the carpet and knocked
boots in that coffin yeah
and if you know and I'd say like you
know hey this doesn't go well you know
I'm kidding
like I'd murder anyone what a great
thing to say I'm kidding I didn't murder
anyone after sex
quit Breckin Meyer I was raised right
yes so that really sanity but you didn't
sleep with the lid oh yeah crazy
otherwise it's just a box I'm not an
animal it's a he would shut the lid
salutely would you lie like this I mean
I probably start off that way it wasn't
big cuz I'm knee-high to a grasshopper
so it was custom-made I mean this was a
sweet ass confident nice where is it now
that was the thing when my dad moved my
dad moving I was 18 and he called me
almost like the kind of like lassie died
call where he was like hey Breck we had
to get rid of the coffin yeah and I was
like dad why and he's like cuz you're 18
and it's a coffin should not have to
explain this it's caught on my posters
it was a really nice coffin I get out I
keep saying that because I think it'll
make me sound normal yeah yeah
you